welcome back to CBS This Morning we have
an exclusive interview with bana
Taylor's boyfriend his name is Kenneth
Walker now he was with Taylor when she
was killed by Louisville police officers
on March 13th he told us that they were
in bed watching a movie when police
raided the apartment as part of a
Narcotics investigation that was
targeting her ex-boyfriend we should
point out that Kenneth Walker and bana
Taylor do not have a criminal history
and no illegal drugs were found in that
home we went to Louisville over the
weekend to talk with Kenneth Walker
about that
night to the world just a hashtag a
picture and all of that but to me it was
much
more more than a girlfriend too I think
that's what I want the world to know the
most that was my best friend the most
important person pretty much to me on
the earth and they took her let's go
back to that day what kind of day was it
for you too it was a normal day it was
it was a relaxed day
really just chilling and just being us
you know we we went on a date went out
to eat went back in the house playing
know watching a movie take us to that
moment when your life really changed
forever it was a loud bang at the door
you know nobody was responding when we
were saying who is it you all did ask
who is it several times several times
both of us you there's no response you
know the the police say that they said
several times it's the police if they
knock on the door and say who it was we
can we can hear them it's dead silent I
know a million per sure that nobody
identified
themselves so the next thing you hear
the door flies off the hinges are you
feeling afraid definitely afraid but I I
don't have much room to be afraid cuz I
got somebody here that I got to take
care of so you hear the heavy knocking
and what do you do so now at that point
we're getting up to put on clothes make
ourselves decent to answer the the door
then I grabbed my gun we should also say
you were licensed to carry the gun for
sure that was the one time I had to use
it and if it was the police at the door
and they just said where where the
police me or Banna didn't have a reason
at all not to open the door and see what
they wanted so the doors the doors fly
off the hinges I I let off one shot and
you know I'm figuring if somebody's
trying to break in or something they're
not they're not going to want to do
anything after that and after that what
happens you know I ever heard so many
gunshots like all the same time I never
been to war but I assume that's what war
Probably sounds like one officer fired
six shots officer mattingley officer
crove fired 16 shots officer Hinson
fired 10 shots that is a lot of
Firepower I still try to make sense of
it to this day there's definitely there
was definitely nowhere to hide there
bullets coming in every direction when
did you realize that bana had been
shot I guess in the in the middle of all
the gunfire like she
screamed but like I was holding her hand
you were holding her hand yeah like
while this was happening I pulled her
down to the ground but you know she was
just scared so she just didn't get down
so in the middle of all of this you
realize that she's been hit was she
alive at the time she she was still and
when all the gun fires stopped She was
like bleeding and stuff and I was
holding her know then that's when I
called my mom you called your mom first
yeah I told her that somebody just
kicked in the door and shot Banna and
she's she's freaking out at this point
but she told me to call 911 so I
did 911 operator Harris where their
emergency I don't I don't know what
happened if somebody kiic in the door
ins shot my girlfriend while you're on
the phone you don't know it's the police
I didn't know it was the police not at
all and I even proceeded to tell
911 that you know somebody just kicked
in the door and shot my girlfriend you
know I didn't if I knew who it was I
would have said the police oh I wouldn't
been calling the police on the police
like that doesn't even make sense where
would you shot at I don't know she on
the ground right now I don't know is she
alert and able to talk to
you no she's not
Brie in the midst of me talking to 911
I'm like well Brianna's Mama should know
about this I hung up on them and I
called her mom the police didn't come
rushing in not at all I don't think I
realized that it was the police until I
was on the phone with Brianna's mom I
hear like people outside talking I
thought they was you know coming for
help cuz I called 911 so you think
they're coming to help you yes so when I
come outside there's guns pointed at me
you know I'm being threatened with dogs
and whatever else don't that put your
hands on your
head that's what's going on the officer
asked me was I hit by any bullets I said
no he said that's unfortunate so that
threw me off too so I'm like what's he
mean by that that's unfortunate he said
to you after you've just lost your
girlfriend and you don't know what is
happening what did you think when he
said that I didn't know what to think
and I really wasn't worried about me
only reason I'm even out here is because
only way for her to get help in there is
for me to be out here we were scared no
we didn't know who it
was we didn't even know who it was and I
was in the back of the car I don't know
I got drug all the way down the street
it was cold it was wet I any socks and
shoes on gravel rocks and everything and
they was just dragging me like I had
scabs and stuff on my feet from that
when they take you to the police station
still no socks and still no socks
and shoes when we finally left the scene
we pulled over in like a random parking
lot on manlake which is the street like
at the bottom of the hill down the
street from rih's apartment and another
officer in an unmarked car and he wasn't
in uniform and stuff and he came to my
window but his tone was way different
than everybody else's who was just on
the scene how so different how he told
me that this was a that this was a
misunderstanding and we're going to get
to the bottom of it and asking me did I
need anything did I need water and this
and that hey partner get your name Denis
Walker man uh there was a little bit of
miscommunication I wanted to talk to you
before they left then when I got to the
police headquarters or whatever was they
took the handcuffs off me and everything
I was walking around I went to the
bathroom go ahead and uh when you get in
there you can take the handcuffs off so
clearly y'all know something's wrong cuz
you don't you're allowed to move freely
yeah you don't allegedly shoot at a
shoot a police officer and they take
hand the handcuffs off you were you
surprised to hear that you were accused
of shooting a police off I definitely
was surprised but I was more concerned
about is he okay and is Ranna okay at
this point I still didn't even know if
she was alive or not so when did
officers tell you you were going to be
charged with attempted murder when did
you hear that maybe like five or six in
morning that same night what did you
think I was worried about if Ranna was
okay or not when were you finally told
that Banna didn't make it I never really
got told like directly I saw it on the
news
that's how you heard ban Taylor died on
the news pretty
much and I was in the Cale and it was
like on the news and it said one you
know female dead that confirmed it you
know I didn't know for sure what
condition you know she was in when I
left so I didn't know what they did but
as these body cam videos and stuff come
out I see they did
nothing clearly we see the SWAT team in
there and she was still in there they're
still like casing the apartment with her
lay right there on the ground apartment
4 now a crime scene let's go ahead and
move out all right she's
done
disrespectful do you think if you would
not survive this incident that we would
be hearing the story that we're hearing
today if you had not survived it
definitely not that wouldn't that
wouldn't be a
story you you probably wouldn't even
know about it if I didn't live you
probably wouldn't even know about ban
Taylor
Banna Taylor or Kenny Walker or Kenny
Walker I don't want everybody to know
about Kenny Walker all long as everybody
knows Banna Taylor what do you want us
to know about Banna Taylor just she
would did anything for
anybody she took care of a lot of people
so a lot of people that need her bad
right
now including
me wow a grand jury accepted the
Kentucky attorney general's
recommendation not to charge any
officers for bana Taylor's death both
the Louis Metro Police Department and
attorneys for three individual officers
involved declined our requests for
interviews or for comment I mean I'm
very struck Kenny Walker you can still
see is shattered he's still in a lot of
pain I think this interview was very
difficult for him that night they were
watching a movie called Freedom Riders
and he went to watch it again and he
said he still gets triggered by songs
movies certain types of food and I think
it's so important to discuss to to
stress no criminal record y it was it
was the first time that he's ever fired
his gun when he wasn't on the shooting
range and to this day he goes I'm not
really even sure I hit the police
officer they told me I did but I'm not
really even sure about that I think
everybody in America should watch that
piece because they think they may have
an idea of what happened this will
change your perspective and I think it
comes down to accountability and and and
proportional use of force this is a
legal Kentucky gun owner who fire fired
one shot into what he thought was an
intruder he got 20 plus bullets from
multiple people on the outside who
couldn't see what was happening yeah
that's not proportionate and it's
totally dark in the apartment that was
interesting too about calling 911 he
said why would I call 911 if I thought
it was the police well and clearly by by
what he says to 911 he doesn't
understand what's happened yeah and uh I
mean that's the really compelling part
too is is the way he was treated there
and the way he then the different way he
was treated at the police station you
know suggest do other police officers
think that was a disciplined response to
uh Kenneth Walker's single shot I I I
think that's a question it's a lot of
questions and we've got more of the
interview with Kenneth Walker in our
next next hour we'll have more of what
he says including his reaction to the
Nationwide protest over B Taylor's death
as he said you know to a lot of people
she's a hashtag not to him and how he is
handling his grief